vous avez entendu ce qu'a dit carbon de
16 sur effectivement l'emploi de la
force en france dans le maintien de
l'ordre notamment on a entendu gérald
darmanin à l'assemblée nationale dire
qu'il y aurait si je ne me trompe cinq
cents policiers supplémentaires recrutés
pour lui la réponse c'est de recruter
davantage
est ce que c'est votre avis il faut
recruter davantage mais faut recruter au
bon niveau et avec la qualité qui va
avec et ce qui n'est pas l'objectif de
ce gouvernement
la première année du quinquennat de
monsieur macro où il avait promis de
recruter à peu près de mille policiers
gendarmes il a 300 policiers qui n'ont
pas été recrutés parce qu'il n'y avait
pas le niveau suffisant d'ego dans les
candidats là qui avait 24 il candidat
mais qu'il n'était pas intéressé par la
carrer de police au bon niveau
ces gens là après se retrouvent d'année
en année on a pas on n'attire pas les
bons profils ce qui fait qu'on arrive
comme à l'école de nîmes a récemment
avoir des gens qui ne respectent pas le
couvre-feu en tant qu'élève gardien
avoir des gens qui doivent sortir coûte
que coûte de l'école de police c'est
dire qu'on a quelqu'un qui fume de la
drogue dans une école de police
viré il est juste il perd des points sur
sa moyenne quelqu'un qui conduit bourré
en tant qu'élève gardien il n'est pas
viré il perd des points sur ses moyens
et ses gens là qu'on va retrouver sur le
terrain demain
donc en fait on est sûr de la quantité
mais la quantité sur la médiocrité en
fait on n'embauche pas les bonnes
personnes la formation est pas adéquat
je rappelle aussi par exemple sur la
formation continue la cour des comptes
s'était d'alerté qui avait seulement 51
21 51 % des policiers n'avaient pas fait
leur 3-2 le mans terre avec leurs armes
parce que justement les stands de tir ne
sont pas entretenues et des problèmes
d'après le paiement de cartouches mais
on est toujours sur une logique
budgétaire d'envoyer des policiers sur
le terrain et au final qui se passe dans
tous les procès qui peut y avoir s'il
n'ya jamais jamais à préfet de police
qui est remis au premier rang jamais à
commissaire jamais un chef de service
qui a donné les ordres qui n'a pas fait
les formations qui n'a pas donné le
budget ils sont toujours absents dire
qu'on va pouvoir le terme policiers en
pâture il va y avoir des manifestions
éventuellement blesser ou molestés
d'ailleurs les joueurs n'arrivent pas
pour interpeller les bonnes personnes
donc en fait la formation derrière est
très importante on ne l'a pas il ya une
volonté politique d'opposer économies
par rapport à l'information
j'en veux également pour preuve sur la
formation continue est un cycle de
travail qui était très intéressant pour
les policiers qui permettait d'avoir un
week-end sur deux et un mercredi sur
deux mais qu'avaient également pour la
formation qui permettait d'avoir des
brigades qui se chevauchent une fois par
semaine permettant une brigade de se
dégager du temps pour partir en
formation
le gouvernement a dit malgré les
avantages évidents pour la vie privée et
familiale et sur la formation et la
qualité du travail qu'on peut produire
derrière a dit ça coûte trop cher donc
voilà nous sommes face à des gens qui
ont des billets dans les yeux des
comptes en banque qui ne regarde pas le
dga le fait de manque de formation de
doctrine et qu'ils sont sûrs de la
communication est sur le terrain c'est
dramatique ce qui se peut se passer
comme on peut le voir malheureusement
régulièrement à la fois pour les
policiers des citoyens et
malheureusement les soldes qui rigole
c'est les black blocks qu'on interpelle
quasiment jamais les choix des choix qui
sont évidemment obtenu est édictée par
le préfet de police de paris didier
lallement auquel gérald darmanin à
renouveler son soutien en milieu de
semaine alors que les manifestants
réclamaient sa démission
aucun responsable tout le monde demande
la démission de monsieur l'allemand même
le premier ministre avait demandé la
démission de monsieur l'allemand pour
prendre son poste
donc ça veut dire que personne n'en veut
à bordeaux je rappelle qu'il avait le
cou vers la sphère olivier béziat dans
dix ans que les policiers avaient agi
dans le chaos et qu'on regarde l'enquète
du monde qui a été plus rapide que l'
enquête de l'igpn ce qui est quand même
assez paradoxal voit bien que c'était
quelqu'un qui partait etc
et malgré qu'il ait menti pour couvrir
des policiers il a eu son poste de
préfet de police à paris il a encore
menti également dans la sphère mediapart
la préfecture de police a menti donc en
fait partout il a il ment pour couvrir
les comportements les plus abjects de la
police est aujourd'hui monsieur d'armani
qui ne serait pas fusible qui sautera
mais non en fait c'est pas un fusible le
préfet de police et un responsable de la
situation et au contraire ce que
monsieur darmana fait c'est qu'une fois
de plus par exemple dans la terre michel
est clair il ya quatre policiers qui
sont responsables de leurs actes qu'ils
doivent être sanctionnés mais finalement
c'est les quatre lampistes l'équipe qui
vont être sanctionnés
monsieur l'allemand est parfaitement
courant de la situation de la formation
catastrophique est parfaitement au
courant qu'il ya un manque de suivi
psychologique des effectifs est
parfaitement au courant que dans
certains endroits il ya des problèmes de
racisme
il est parfaitement courant tout ça
monsieur darmana aussi le problème c'est
qu'en france on est face à une équipe
politique qui est dans le déni
je donne un exemple très parlant très
très parlant c'est que nous avons eue en
1986 par exemple monsieur malik
oussékine qui est mort au cours d'une
manifestation parce qu'il y avait des
voltigeurs monsieur charles par soit en
sommes à la grave d'ailleurs un petit
peu hein
et bien justement c'est là où je viens
c'est que monsieur charles pasqua on
pourra pas taxé de laxisme qui était un
des derniers ministre de la
ailleurs apprécié et respecté des
policiers a dissous les braves présenter
des excuses à la famille il ya une
réponse politique à la hauteur de ce qui
s'était passé en france que ce soit
monsieur darmana monsieur macro on est
dans le déni
il n'y a pas de violence policière dans
un état de droit monsieur macron
monsieur darmana je ne veux pas qu'on
parle de voleurs ce policière pire ils
se mordent des gens qui meurent à cause
de fautes professionnelles aux policiers
quand il a dit j'étouffe quand on parle
de violences policières mais quel manque
de respect pour la famille de cédric
schille via sept individus cachés dans
son bureau place beauvau met de l'huile
sur le feu met en danger les policiers
incitent les gens à la haine de la
police et fait le jeu de tous ces
extrémistes qui nous attaquent donc à
partir de là avec cette équipe au
gouvernement les plus extrémistes sont
un parce qu'ils nous mettent en danger
sans assumer les responsabilités je les
invite 6 assumer réellement qu'il prenne
un bouclier une matraque un casque et
qui viennent en première ligne sur le
terrain monsieur macro qui avait dit
venez me chercher
caché derrière son temps dans de
sécurité monsieur darmanin qui fait le
beau et qui n'est pas capable de
respecter les règles de confinement en
alors courir en dehors des zones parce
que c'est monsieur le ministre
donc avec ces gens qui ne sont pas
exemplaires qui crachent sur tout le
monde
voilà le résultat c'est le chaos dans
les villes c'est le chaos dans la rue
alors que finalement il ya une minorité
d'extrémistes qu'on pourrait canaliser
et pour les plus violents qui commettent
des délits et des crimes
on pourrait les interpeller ce n'est pas
la volonté politique à volonté politique
ce la propagande c'est de la
communication pour faire passer des lois
liberticides
alors que les lois actuelles ne sont pas
appliquées et elles sont pourtant
nécessaires donc appliquons déjà les
choses qui existent voyons ce qui marche
calmant les esprits en fait je repense à
cette phrase assez dramatique de
ballades tibétaine diakhaby pour imposer
une réforme nous userons de violence et
malheureusement celle inverse des
valeurs qui fondent la république à 16
est-ce que monsieur louis blanc avait
dit guy au 19e siècle troisième
république de bulletins de vote a
remplacé la violence dans la rue parce
qu'il n'a su pacifier les débats quand
la loi est dans l'intérêt général il n'y
a pas tout ce qu'on peut voir
aujourd'hui si la loi et le consensus
national
il n'y a pas ça les policiers peuvent se
recentrer sur leur vraie mission de
lutter contre les crimes et les délits
et aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le corps
doit se concentrer sur la politique
merci à vous merci alexandre langlois
pour ce coup de gueule en tout cas on a
bien compris le message
merci en tout cas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions en direct ce soir sur arte
france
[Applaudissements]